>> Thank you very much for preparing this
opportunity to discuss about
a little bit to you words about the World
Economic Forum this year.
And to my understanding, this year this forum
was more brave than
previous years.
And they could raise a part, some parts of
their global problems.
If you look to three keywords of this year's
pamphlets of World
Economic Forum, you will find these three
words: Rethinking,
redesigning, and rebuilding trust.
These three words shows the world is facing
with entrusting, facing
with the bad thinking and wrong thinking,
and the design which is there
for that managing of the world is not acceptable.
This is part of the problem.
But the second step is what is the main root
causes of these problems?
We should find out.
The root causes of this problem.
To my understanding, first the mechanism -- rules
and regulations which
is created not only for the economy affairs
but also for the political
and social affairs goes back to more than
six decades ago, of the
second World War.
We should rethink about these mechanisms which
is called [INAUDIBLE].
The second point is who are going to rethink,
redesign, and rebuild?
Who are they?
Are they the same thing which have created
these problems?
Are they, again, the winner of the second
World War?
It can't be.
If they rethink, they will think in the same
direction.
If they redesign, they will design in the
same direction.
And definitely rebuilding the same building.
That's why we need some new.
We are facing the different problems in the
world today.
The drug problem which the young generation
are facing, $60 billion is
the black money which is coming from the opium
only.
If we move to heroin and the others, it will
be hundreds of billions of
dollars.
A part of this black money goes for terrorism
but the main part goes to
the banking system to different markets.
What the money laundering money thing systems
are doing for this
hundred, hundreds of billions of dollars in
the world economy, I think
these are good topics for thinking.
Thank you for your patience to hear me.